salut je finis le rubik's cube parce
qu'il y en a que ça perturbe quand il
est pas fait sur le budget on vient de
se faire une bonne semaine bien costaud
et je vais recadrer cette vidéo c'est
n'importe quoi
oui c'est père si mal voici aujourd'hui
10 astuce mnémotechnique en mode
mitraillette pour retenir tout et
surtout n'importe quoi ah oui j'oubliais
génériques
pour le changement d'heure deux fois par
an vous savez jamais ce que vous devez
faire avec votre réveil je vais vous le
dire en octobre e.on reculent d'une
heure et en avril on avance avait 2
avril en avance octobre- comme recul
s'est jamais vraiment en avril ou en
octobre mais c'est toujours vers cette
période et avec ça vous allez arrêter de
ne pas savoir 2e les accents alors moi
j'ai toujours galéré dans ma vie avec
les accents aigus des accents graves je
sais jamais lequel il fallait mettre
il existe une astuce mnémotechnique pour
les accents il suffit de vous fier aux
sons c'est pas mal c'est pas mieux
non bon il suffit que vous gardiez en
tête le mot élèves parce que dans élèves
vous avé l'accent aigu l'accent grave et
lev ci vous garder cela en tête
à chaque fois vous vous répétez ce mot
dans la tête et vous servez si vous
devez mettre un accent aigu oued accent
grave je voulais dit hier je suis né à
la rochelle à la rochelle on fait
souvent du bateau et on a une astuce
pour retenir bâbord et tribord grâce aux
mots batterie vous pensez juste à
batterie dans votre tête mais atteignant
même si vous voulez parce que dans
batterie basse et à gauche est restée à
droite donc d'abord à gauche tribord à
droite catherine game astuce
mnémotechnique mais ça fait une vitesse
affolante
alors oui l'abus d'alcool ce n'est pas
bon pour la santé c'est surtout pas bon
pour la mémoire
et pourtant il ya quelque chose à
retenir facilement sur les boissons
anisées grâce à pastis 51
ceci n'est pas un placement de produit
pastis 51 nous rappelle juste par son
nom que ces cinq volumes d'eau pour un
volume de pastis et le plus drôle c'est
qu'ils n'ont même pas fait exprès ils
ont juste lancé cette marque là en 1951
l'article antarctique mais c'est ou qui
y est en haut qui en bas c'est trop
compliqué j'ai un truc très simple pour
me rappeler c'est une petite
visualisation l'antarctique il ya plus
de l'être que dans l'arctique donc comme
il ya plus de l'être moi dans ma tête il
est plus lourd et comme il est plus
lourd il pèse plus lourd donc il est
tout en bas donc l'antarctique et au sud
malin de fabien ce tu me fais penser
stalagmites et stalactites qui monte et
qui descend il ya m dans stalagmites il
ya un thé dans stalactites et bien vous
vous rappellerez grâce à ça que les
stalagmites ça monte donc sa part du sur
les ça monte et les stalactites sa tombe
avec le thé ça tombe ça tombe du plafond
père le bas du coup si on tombe rarement
vers le haut ce qui nous amène à la 7è
comment est ce qu on convertit un maïs
en kilomètres nous amène à la 7e quand
on convertit des miles en kilomètres un
marty c'est très important pour
atteindre les 80 animal
ce à l'heure vous avez juste à retenir
une image c'est une paire de ciseaux
9ème pas la paire en entier juste la
moitié 1 6 au 9 quoi et bien parce que
une maille égal 1 6 09 le zéro ça fait
un peu penser à un autre et pratique
dans le milieu nautique
8e c'est un truc qu'on m'a appris
récemment pour retenir tous les
présidents américains depuis la seconde
guerre mondiale la roue est troué essaye
la clé dit johnson qui nie ouais mais la
ford et sans carter je ricane
je vais au premier puis songe fait un
clin d'oeil je veux deuxième buisson et
aux merveilles une belle baraque
la rousse et pour roosevelt et roué
c'est pour truman et cei pour les
annuaires la clé la clé c'est qu'est en
anglais pour kennedy johnson ce port
johnson là c'était assez simple qui nie
pour nixon la ford et sans carter donc
ford et carter je ricane c'est un peu
plus compliqué c'est pour reagan je vais
au premier puis son c'est pour bush
senior et je fais un clin d'oeil pour
klein pour clinton je vaux deuxième hui
sont donc c'est bush junior et je
découvre une belle baraque pour barack
obama pour la 9e ont fait un plus simple
la neuvième c'est par rapport au
croissant de lune vous savez quand ça
forme un espèce de deux croissants en
fait ça s'appelle un concert peut-être
que vous ne savez pas c'est le premier
croissant lune ou le dernier croit
semblait alors il ya une bonne astuce
pour ça vous tracez une barre imaginaire
dans votre tête vous n'aurez jamais
d'escabeau assez grand entre les deux
pointes du croissance il croise un comme
ça vous passer une barre comme ça entre
les deux points vous la trace et
mentalement vers le haut et vers le bas
et vous voyez ce que sa forme si vous
pouvez former un des avec sais que ce
sera le dernier croissant de lune et si
vous pouvez former un pc que ce sera le
premier croissant de lune dixième et
dernière astuce
on a parlé du président américain serait
peut-être bien de parler des présidents
français je vais vous donner lors de
tous les présidents français de la vème
république
eh ouais grâce à la phrase suivante 12
patrick gauloise mélangeant chat
solitaire hargneux là c'est un procédé
mnémotechnique on se base que sur la
première lettre donc douce pour de
gaulle patrie pour pompidou gauloise
pour giscard d'estaing mélangeant pour
mitterrand chat pour chirac solitaire
pour sarkozy hargneux pour hollande
voilà j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
plu
ça change un petit peu ça fait plaisir
c'est plus léger et vous pourrez y
revenir dans un an quand vous voulez
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé si ça
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à le faire
savoir en mettant d'un geste engagé un
pouce en l'air n'oubliez pas de le faire
c'est toujours très important vous
pouvez également vous abonner à la
chaîne avant de partir puisque le mental
blog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un
nom du 1er janvier au 31 décembre
et ouais donc rendez vous demain à 11h
ciao